-Our first guests tonight
are two Hollywood legends
that also happen to be brothers.
Their new book, "The Boys: A
Memoir of Hollywood and Family"
is available tomorrow.
Please welcome to the show
Ron and Clint Howard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
-Thank you for being here,
fellas.
-Wow!
-So, "The Boys,"
this is not a -- this is
a nickname your mom had
not just for the two of you,
correct?
-All three of her boys.
-The two boys and her husband.
She called you guys "the boys."
-So, it's a little tribute
to mom in addition
to all the other stories
that focus a lot on dad.
But she --
without her, her energy,
her vision, her creativity,
none of it would have happened.
-And one of the things
you guys talk about
is that your dad --
there was maybe a bit
of a mythology about
how your parents met,
that, over the years,
he became a little honest,
a little more forthcoming
about the truth.
-Well, he waited --
he waited till mom passed
before he really
spilled the beans.
-Okay.
-That is true.
Well, there was a whole --
Look, their whole love story
is kind of a fairy tale.
It's one of the reasons
that we wanted to tell it.
These two people, they had --
you know, they, later in life
called themselves
the sophisticated hicks.
They had no business
dreaming of Hollywood.
Dad wanted to be
a singing cowboy.
Couldn't carry a tune.
Thank God nobody told him.
[ Laughter ]
But they met at
University of Oklahoma,
they fell in love,
and, you know, the reality is,
they ran off to be
in the business together.
They ran to New York,
this magical place,
to try to do it,
and they actually succeeded.
But the story was always,
"Yeah, you know,
I left, and I got
a summer-stock thing,
and she went to New York,
and then, lo and behold, we --
we discovered
each other there again,
and then we --
we somehow got cast
in this children's theater
thing together.
We both got jobs!
Wow! And then we just, you know,
we fell in love there,
and eventually we got married
in Kentucky because
they had no waiting period."
This whole long story.
They ran off.
They shacked up.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, come on.
And dad finally,
when mom passed, he said,
"You know..."
What am I?
Probably 48 years old.
"You know, that story
we told you --"
"Dad, dad! Just --
You don't have to go there.
We got it.
We got it."
-But this is --
so you guys, obviously,
got started very young.
So young, Clint,
that you do not remember
your first job on television.
-Oh, no. Not at all.
In fact, it was probably --
Well, I've been
in the business 60 years.
-Yeah.
-I've been paying attention
for 55 years.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I sort of had a blackout there
for the first five years.
-I do want to show
this amazing photo.
You were in an episode of --
I think you were 7 years old
when you were in an episode
of "Star Trek."
-Yes.
-The original "Star Trek."
And what's the name
of your character?
Do you remember that?
-Oh, yes.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
I was Commander Balok
in "The Corbomite Maneuver."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
And as you can tell --
as you can tell, I wasn't having
a very happy day there
when I was getting
the skull cap put on.
But it was better than the first
alternative that they gave me.
They really wanted
to shave my head.
And as a kid going
to second grade, I thought,
"There is no way
I'm gonna go back to school
with a bald head."
-Yeah.
I mean, even being
on "Star Trek"
couldn't make up for that.
But your dad, he had a sense --
You know, obviously,
he had done -- you know,
he was in show business,
and he had kids
who were gonna be in it,
and he wanted you guys
to have normal lives,
but he also
wanted you to thrive.
And so tell the story
about how he would fake
a boom mic just so that
you would be used to it
if you were ever on set?
-Yeah. Well, I mean, he --
My very first audition,
I was still only 3 years old.
And, you know,
we learned the scene.
Turned out,
he was incredibly gifted
at basically teaching kids
how to understand how to act,
not perform
but really understand
what was going on in a scene.
So I had memorized the scene,
I worked it out.
And it was for a movie called
"The Journey."
And he realized that when you --
I got for my screen test,
there were gonna be
a lot of distractions.
So he got an out-of-work
acting buddy to come over,
and they hung a bucket
from a string, and he would,
like, move it around.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, "Oh, no,
don't look up at that.
Just look at the other actor."
My mom had a cereal box,
pretending to be a camera
that was kind of moving around.
[ Laughter ]
And so, it was that kind of --
A little like Tiger Woods' dad
yelling in the backswing.
-Yeah.
-But much kinder.
-Well, I will tell you this.
I have a 3-year-old,
and if there was a bucket
in the room, forget it.
[ Laughter ]
You know.
If there was a bucket
within eyesight,
he'd be like "What?"
-Mom and dad understood the
distractions of the business.
-Yeah.
-Both the physical distractions
and then
the psychological distractions.
And they were really good
at heading those off.
You know?
They always --
Boy, they gave us
so much confidence.
Mom and dad gave us
It was just -- you know, it was
a beautiful life growing up.
And also,
it was a beautiful life
being this guy's little brother.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-But now --
That's very nice.
But you also had to negotiate
a little, Clint, because you,
at a very young age, obviously,
you knew that you wanted
to be behind the camera.
-Yeah.
-You made some short films.
And you were very kind
to cast Clint,
but you wanted to make sure
that there was
a little something in it
for you, right?
-Well, I was getting more and
more serious about making films,
and I wanted
to enter a contest --
The Kodak
Teenage Filmmakers Contest.
And they had a category called
"The One Reeler,"
where you had to plan out
all of your shots
and you couldn't edit it.
You just had to shoot it
and send it in.
And I built the whole thing
around this young kid.
And it was kind of
a "Twilight Zone"-ish
sort of thing.
There was a part for Clint,
part for dad.
And we're getting ready
to do it.
Something I carefully planned.
I'm very nervous about it.
And I asked Clint to do it.
He sort of said yeah.
We get there.
We're getting ready to shoot,
and he says, "I -- I hear
there's a cash prize involved
if you win something."
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Yeah. You can --
You know, first is $200.
Second's, you know, $150."
And he said, "Well,
I'm gonna need half of that."
[ Laughter ]
-And I told him, I said,
"Hey, listen, bud.
If you want to scour
the neighborhood in Toluca Lake
and see if you can find another
12-year-old that wants to be
in your short, go right ahead."
[ Laughter ]
-And you won.
-I -- I came in second.
-So, did he show up
for the money?
-Hell yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, the minute --
I'm there, beaming --
"I got a -- I came in second!
And he's...
[ Laughter ]
-We had dad mediate.
Dad came in and immediately
mediated, and I prevailed.
And I got the $75.
-I mean, it must've --
You guys also talk about the
fact that you were obviously,
you know, you were in shows
that were incredibly popular.
You know, "Andy Griffith,"
and you were in "Gentle Ben,"
and people knew who you were.
And I always kind of wondered
about something like this,
because again, you went back,
and you tried
to have a normal life.
You played basketball.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But you're playing basketball,
and every single kid
knows who you are.
Right? Hold on.
I have a great photo.
There you are there.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I guess
it made it pretty easy
for the other team
to try to get in your head.
-There was always a lot of that.
There was a lot of that
at school.
You know?
And it was --
You know, it was something
I had to learn to cope with,
whether that meant
I had to get in a fight,
a wrestling match or something.
Later, when I got
into high school,
and we're playing at away games,
you know,
they rode me pretty hard.
And at some schools,
they did this thing
where I'd be
at the free-throw line,
having to take
a couple of foul shots,
and all of a sudden,
you'd hear the band,
and the band would go...
[ Singing to the tune of
"The Andy Griffith Show" theme ]
And then, "Miss it, Opie!"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm here, and --
But I am proud to say
that I was
a 60% free-throw shooter at home
where the crowd was friendly.
-Yeah.
-87% on the road.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
I want to show this photo
because I feel like I've seen
so many photos
of the "Happy Days"
softball team over the years.
-Oh, it was a blast.
-And here you are
with Henry Winkler,
who, I think we can
all attest -- bad guy.
Just a deeply...
-Miserable S.O.B.
-Miserable human being!
-Literally the nicest person
I've ever met.
-Godfather to all my kids,
by the way.
-Really?
Well, you've chosen well.
Clint, true story --
you taught him to pitch?
-Yes, I did.
I played high school baseball,
and I had
some pretty good chops
and had the opportunity
to play on
the "Happy Days" softball team.
-He was sort of a ringer.
We grabbed him onto the team.
-And Henry had no skill at all
as a baseball player,
and yet within
a few short weeks,
he had learned to develop
this wonderful pitch
that sort of drifted inside.
And he could tie up
really good hitters.
-Well, much like your father,
you were a good teacher.
-Yes, yeah.
Softball pitcher whisperer.
[ Laughter ]
-We all need one.
Gentlemen, congrats on the book.
It's such a lovely read.
And thanks so much for making
the time for us tonight.